I was washing the dishes and then I was
like cuz my my my sister came along you
know why I'm doing this because I don't
want her to come home to a dirty home
and I wanted and then I realized no I'm
washing the dishes because I want her to
see that I do chores so that she can do
the majority of these other chores like
I I just analyze myself like oh piece of
ish like you and then there's other
reasons like so I'm pouring water for
someone else first yes why because like
oh no I'm such a gracious host but there
was something else there I forgotten the
reason but it's like I want to appear
gracious or or I wanted I I thought
there was like a a bit of lint in it so
I'm like giving it to you I forgot what
it was and I have this list I catalog
anytime I come up with them one just so
that I could remind myself like do not
think that you're benevolent most of the
time I love that I that's awesome man
that